I spent 18 months turning my second
brain into my living research memory.
Let me explain.
So, within my second brain, I currently
have over 5,000 notes in Obsidian and
another 5,000 notes in Readwise and some
scattered in Notion and Google Drive.
And all of this is growing on every week
250 files per month.
And this is what I want. On the left,
you can see my whole Obsidian vault,
this huge mass. And whenever I start
working on something such as an article,
a new project, a new code base, a new
feature, or whatever, I want to actually
pull high-signal notes that are actually
useful for my current work.
And you would ask yourself, why not use
directly Codex Cloud or Notebook LM? And
I think it's that I am. But you need a
system that sits between those harnesses
and your second brain. Okay, so let's go
back to the root of my problem, which is
that I'm always losing my research. For
example, my reading list is a graveyard.
When I'm scrolling social media and I
save that cool X post, a new article, a
new new YouTube video, a GitHub
repository, it doesn't matter. Whenever
I actually want to start working on
something, I never recall what I have in
my second brain or I have to spend a ton
of time actually finding meaningful
notes that I can use in my work, right?
And another problem that I have is that
I want the system to actually be
anchored into my personal notes, into my
personal values, into my personal faith.
I want the system to be personal to
reflect my own thoughts, right? And
that's why in today's video, Louis
François and I will teach you how to
build your own AI research OS. This also
comes with code, so you can also try it
out yourself.
And I'm Paul Yushin. I'm the founder and
CEO of Decoding AI, where I do a ton of
content on courses on how to ship AI
products. And I'm also the co-author of
the LM Engineers Handbook bestseller.
And the system, the AI research OS that
I will teach you in this video is the
system that I use in my daily work. And
now I will pass the torch to Luis
François.
>> Thanks, Paul. So, I'm Luis François
Bouchard. I'm the co-founder and CTO of
Towards AI, where we build educational
courses. And I'm also the creator of
What's AI, a YouTube channel where I
explain AI engineering techniques. I
used to explain AI research before.
Now, I'm focusing on AI engineering. I'm
also the author of the book Building AI
systems for production. And before that,
I was a PhD student. So, I honestly make
research for a living. I used to do a
PhD, as I said, in AI and doing tons of
research and research work. Now, I build
courses, I write videos, I research for
videos, I build trainings for companies
for a living. And all of these
things that I do start with a very good
research. And also leveraging tons of
knowledge and insights that we get at
Towards AI from building for clients.
So, I have tons of notes as well, just
like Paul. And we try to leverage them
the best possible.
And as you'll see, we'll build some sort
of tool to leverage our second brain,
where as you'll see, there will be some
differences between how I use it and how
Paul uses it. And that's the core goal
of the repository that we built and on
this project is that we want you to
adapt it for your needs. The whole goal
is how can we make research better, but
more specifically, how can we better
leverage what we have?
So, let's dive into it.
And first, we need to figure out which
tool to use and when, because this
whole
research system that we built is not for
every query.
If you just need a fast answer, like a
few quick questions or just
something where that that you would just
Google, basically. Well, obviously, just
Google it or ask ChatGPT, Cloud,
whichever system you want. But, the
problem when doing that is that if you
have a lot of following up question or
it's a bigger project that you need to
build on and have basically a very long
context or tons of information to share,
relying on ChatGPT isn't ideal. And it
also means that you are fully dependent
on the architecture that OpenAI or
ChatGPT's team built.
So, the next step here is to ask
yourself for a more complex problem, do
you need to act quickly or do you want
to build some next feature and and do
something very difficult? If you just
have a small repo for a quick change or
write one article, just do one thing
that you know won't be repeatable that
much, definitely use Codex or Cloud Code
or some agent that you trust. Sometimes,
you need to keep on digging to make it
better, to improve efficiency, optimize
it more. And so, typically, when you
have to do that, you want your research
sources, your research to stick and to
be able to refer to them in the future.
So, if you want a process like this
where the sources that you find, the
notes that you take stick around in time
and have an agent be able to leverage
that efficiently and being able to come
back to these information, to ask
follow-up questions, to digest content
even more. And right now, for instance,
when I make a new video, I want also the
agent and the system to understand the
previous videos I made to not duplicate
content, to not repeat myself, and to
refer to some other content.
In this case,
there are some tools that are very
interesting that you might have tried
before, like NotebookLM, that is super
powerful to do research, to digest
content efficiently, and to come back to
it. But, the problem with NotebookLM is
that is Well, first, the main problem is
that you don't own it. You cannot do
anything you want with it. You cannot
personalize as much as possible.
It's not agent native.
And it's obviously weak for coding tasks
since it's just
browser based. So, it's far from ideal
from something that Paul and I needed
and that most AI engineers need in
general.
So, if you need your agents to be able
to leverage all you do,
uh whether it is a big research,
a new video, whatever you write, you do,
you code, you typically want your other
agents, your other projects to be able
to leverage what you learn from what you
just did. And one thing that we advise
especially for production, obviously for
product, is to build some sort of
retrieval rag pipeline with vector
databases. But, this needs an
infrastructure. It's not really
human-friendly to be able to digest
quickly, to check notes, to make edits.
It's hard to inspect by hand. You need
to build everything around it. It's
definitely far from ideal for just
something I want to use on a daily
basis. Obviously, it's super powerful at
scale, very interesting especially in a
product. But, as I said, this project is
for us. And I don't want something live,
super professional as a product. I just
want something I will use and that my
agents and different projects can
leverage as best as possible.
So, the last question to ask ourselves
here is that
if you want everything there but more
personalization, so a personalized
research assistant
that builds some sort of Wikipedia that
compounds over time and and is easily
inspectable and usable where
you have tons of sources, documents,
videos,
comparisons, implementations,
new research, new topics that you keep
on adding and that you keep on wanting
to leverage and review easily, this is
where you may want to build something
yourself. And in our case, we built a
personalized research OS that we will
share
in this talk with exactly what we built
and how. But, the downside is that it
definitely needs a bit more setup than
just opening Cloud Code. Right now, the
main problem with using Cloud Code and
other agentic tool is that you give
Codex links, PDFs, and different
information, for example, my most recent
Loop Engineering video,
and then the next session you use Codex,
you have to paste it all again or ask it
to use skills.
And whatever structure that Codex or
ChatGPT, whatever tool that you use,
build on the fly to leverage what you
did, the scripts it ran, the scripts it
had, you all lost it or kept it inside a
skill that you have to ask it to reuse,
and that usually isn't ideal and just
grows and grows over time.
And the problem is that all this
information that you give to the model
is not the bottleneck. The bottleneck is
how can you leverage it in the future?
Meaning that with an agent, the context
window becomes everything, the database,
the file system, the memory, the
reasoning space. It has to do it all,
and when you stop the conversation, it
loses everything. And the thing is that
we don't need necessarily to provide
more and more and more context for a
better research. You need a proper
memory and context management, and
ideally some personality with it,
especially in my case when I do videos.
So, what we did is that we decided to
build a system with plain files, mostly
markdown files, that we can leverage
easily and that agents can leverage
easily. I won't detail it very much here
because Paul will talk about it in
depth.
And as I said, Paul has like 5,000 or
something notes. I have just a few
hundred, but that's just to say that we
need to consider that we didn't start
from nothing. We already both had some
sort of large database.
In my case, I made hundreds of videos
and I take many notes. So, I still need
to leverage these years of content that
I already made and tons of meetings that
I have with my team, with clients when
we build for them that I want to
leverage as well because we learn a lot
by building for people. We have
highlights from interesting tweets that
I see, interesting articles that I see,
and I want all my projects to be able to
leverage my agent skills. So, I decided
to pivot and instead of having a folder
for Cloud Code skills and having all my
meeting recaps in Granola and having
years of notes on Apple Notes and the
tweets on the saved Chrome tab, instead,
I moved everything automatically into
Obsidian. It's just a note reader,
obviously, so you don't have to use
that. You can just save it locally, but
I used Codex to set up everything so
that Granola is automatically saved
there, my notes are now on Obsidian just
because it's a nice UI, I like it, and I
can use it from my phone, my computer,
my Windows, Mac, everything. So,
anyways, I moved everything to Obsidian,
which means that it's saved locally in
my file system, which means it's
basically my companion for researching
and building everything I build now.
And what we built, obviously, leverages
that. We built a repo called AI Research
OS for this workshop where
it's basically just skills for Cloud
Code and Codex with plugins to be able
to do a very deep research about a topic
or a simpler search or distillation,
different tools that you can use. The
most useful and complete one will be the
research tool that I use, for example,
when I kick off a new video topic. And
the goal of this repo is to have you
implement it,
install the cloud plugins from it, and
tune it to your needs. Right now, it can
connect to, as I said, Obsidian with my
local notes. It can use Readwise,
Notebook LM, your GitHub repos, any
links that you send for GitHub or
YouTube videos, and
web links, obviously, and documents. But
there are tons of things missing, as we
will discuss in the end, that you can
easily implement, just asking Cloud
Coder or Codex to do so. Like for
example, I implemented the YouTube video
transcript in
honestly a few seconds, just one prompt.
It's super easy for Codex to implement
it. So, the thing is that this whole
repository and this whole project is a
very useful companion for my own work.
But, as I said, it implements tons of
features and state-of-the-art context
management and memory management
techniques that I believe AI engineers
need to know.
And now, Paul will dive into all this
three-layer system that we built with
the raw content, the index that I
mentioned, and the wiki-like
synthesized version of all your notes,
all your research, all your work. So,
he'll cover everything we did, how it
ended up, and show how to use it.
>> Okay. So, now I want to go over the
three versions of our system and how it
progressed over time, and most
importantly, why we added more
complexity.
So, in the first version,
we wanted to scope it just to create
lessons for our agent engineering
course. So, we wanted to keep it super
simple, where we had as input a topic
and a research MD as output. So, within
the input, we had the topic plus a set
of golden links, which were manually
handpicked by us.
We applied this deep research algorithm,
and we had as output a static research
MD file.
And if we go
zoom into the architecture,
we first scraped the links of the golden
links, right? Because we already know
them and we use them as seed for context
for the deep research algorithm, which
was a really powerful technique because
we had more context on how to frame our
questions.
And during the query rounds, we
basically used the very classic deep
research algorithm where we had one main
agent, the orchestrator, which created
multiple questions based on the
initial topic and the scraped context.
And each agent managed its own question
and used Gemini grounded in Google to to
query basically Google and gather
multiple resources and each
agent gather these resources, which
returned multiple links and created some
executive summaries of each link. And
then [snorts] it passed all this
information back to the agent to the
main agent where the main agent
basically aggregated all this
information into a summarized way so it
did not exploded the context. And we did
this for three rounds. So basically
after three rounds of generating six
queries per round, we ended up with like
40-50 links in total.
So you can imagine that there's a lot of
noise over there. So that's why we also
applied a ranking algorithm where we
wanted to like find
the the information with the highest
signal. And basically we compared each
source against the topic, the initial
topic of the user. And like that, we
fully scraped only the top K elements
based on the ranking score. And for the
rest of the of the links, we just kept
the summaries. And then we compiled
everything into this research MD file as
a single flat file which we used for
each lesson of our course in in our
particular use case.
But as you can imagine, it was pretty
limited. For the course, it worked great
right away. We generated 35 lessons
really quick, but we wanted more. So, we
started to aim this deep research loop
to the
second brain as well, right? Before, it
was targeting only the public web, which
made this a pretty generic, and we had
to manually find all those golden links.
So, by aiming this deep research loop to
the second brain, where we basically
organically keep track of all the
information that of all the research
that we really want and is filtered by
us,
we can organically gather all those
golden rings
into our deep research algorithm.
So, let's look at how this new algorithm
looks like. It's basically the same
loop, right? But now we target our own
sources instead of just the public web.
Now, for input, we have only the topic
because we don't need the golden links.
As I said, the golden links are actually
a reflection of our second brain system.
In theory, you can also add them if you
really want to, but that's the beauty of
this new strategy because you can just
put as input some topic and we'll find
everything that it needs.
And then we use this topic only as seed
for for for the context to generate the
the queries. And now we do the same deep
research algorithm, right? The same
query rounds, but instead of targeting
only the public web, now we plugged in
all our second brains, such as the our
Obsidian, our Readwise, our Notebook LM,
our GitHub. You can also use, for
example, Gemini deep research for this,
like similar to how we we use notebook
LM or you can extend this with whatever
you want. For example, YouTube, uh
Google Drive, Notion, or whatever makes
sense on your infrastructure. The idea
is that now we are target our queries
from the deep research algorithm to our
second brain plus the public web.
And after we apply the same algorithm
such as ranking, fully scraping,
summaries, and compile everything into
this research MD file.
But now we have another problem, right?
This this research MD file is static.
It's a pile of static data. And usually
research is not static, right? So, after
you end up with with this file, you most
often realize
that you want to ask another question or
some information is stale and you don't
need it anymore. Or or basically, you
want more out of this research MD file.
And we which means that you need to
start all of this from scratch. And the
operation that I showed you uh above is
an extensive operation. It consumes a
lot of tokens and it takes a lot of
time. So, you don't want to run it from
scratch.
And that's why you need to add a wiki
layer on top of it.
And that's why V3 of this system is
actually a deep research algorithm
plus an LM knowledge base on top of it,
aka the wiki layer.
So, the new algorithm looks like this.
So, we have sources in and a wiki out.
And the sources, as I said before, can
be like Obsidian, notebook LM, Google
Drive,
or YouTube, Notion, even custom URLs,
right? That that's also powerful as
well, where you use tools such as
a Bright Data to to parse basically any
single page application, any type of
site, any type of public information
that's out there. We can put it in. And
then you apply the same deep research
algorithm.
You store everything into raw files,
right? Instead of compiling everything
into research and D file, now we store
each file individually.
And we create an index out of all these
files.
And ultimately, we generate a wiki on
top of it, and which we can query. We
can query basically the wiki plus the
index. Okay, so this is just the
high-level architecture of the new
system. Let's zoom into it.
So, what do I want to start with is that
you should forget the infra structure
you think you need, such as vector
databases, knowledge graphs, semantic
search, text search.
All that is beautiful, but add a lot of
complexity, especially for like this
personal wikis, personal research
operating systems that you want to use
very lightly. So, I want a system just
based on files, right? A simple
mechanism that's that's very rooted into
how your computer works.
And that's why we'll create all the
system just based on files and just
based on references.
So,
no database, just a simple index based
on references. And how how this works?
We have an agent
that reads an index.yaml file that's
basically a catalog of your all your
data plus the summaries of of each
source and some metadata around it. For
example, here on the right, you can see
part of an index.yaml file that contains
10 sources and 38 wiki pages as
derivatives
of these sources, where uh we can see
there into the sources list of the YAML
file the first uh source, for example.
And as you can see, it has like the the
the link to the original file plus some
metadata, such the origin, the title,
the authors, the the the publication
date, the summary, and and things things
like this, which can be flexible, right?
And the next step is that based on this
index.yaml file, we need to point to all
the wiki pages, to all the wiki
derivatives, to all the raw sources. So,
basically, this index.yaml file is an
entry point for our agent, right? It's
what we will give to our agent to
actually reason on how to find our data.
It's an index, ultimately, right?
So, the next step is to understand how
the wiki actually looks like. So, on the
left, you can see the high-level
structure of the wiki, where we have the
raw folder, the wiki folder, and the
index. In the raw folder, we actually
just have the raw data, which is
immutable. You don't want to touch that.
The And the index points to everything
that we need. And in the wiki, we
actually have derivatives created by the
LLM, which contains things such as
comparisons between multiple concepts,
entities, or just simple notes as a
reflection of our questions or
repositories that we ingested, and we
can create multiple notes based on a on
on a repository, right? Or open
questions that based on our questions
that LLM couldn't answer yet. And
everything that you can analyze on top
of your raw data.
And on the right, based on Obsidian, we
can see like the sub graph reflected
just based on in this index. And this is
just like the first iteration, but as
the the the the wiki grows, you can see
connections made between entities and
concepts. For example, concepts are
things such as tool registry, context
compaction, sandboxing, or entities are
open code, closed code, MCP, right? So,
as you can see,
you can beautifully can start visually
and practically create connections.
Now, the next obvious question is how do
we actually query this wiki? So, as I
said, the agent will have as input this
index.yaml file, which contains
summaries and metadata about
each source. But what happens next,
right? The next step is actually to look
into the source wiki page. Where the
source wiki page is like an executive
summary of each page. Which is basically
not just a summary, but a more expanded
summary of of each source. And sometimes
the agent just looks into this, gets
what it needs, and goes back. Which is
very token efficient, right?
And if it doesn't find
within this uh source wiki page, we also
need links into the wiki derivative,
such as concepts, entities, notes,
comparisons, and so and so forth.
And only if it doesn't find the
necessary information up to this point,
it needs and it actually reads the whole
raw source, right? Which basically
contains the whole article, the whole
paper, the the the whole video, or
whatever. And this makes just through
pure referencing and creating this
simple hierarchy, this makes everything
very token efficient. Now, the beautiful
part is that this wiki is actually
alive, right? For example, every
question leaves a trace into your wiki.
So for every question, the LLM can
create a new concept file, a new notes
[snorts] file, a new comparison file.
And every question is is tracked into a
log. So basically, the the the wiki
doesn't evolve only when you ingest new
data or do a deep research round, it
actually evolves as you start talking
with it, right? That's the beautiful
part, actually. And like that, you can
see a true reflection of of yourself, of
what you haven't understood, of all your
questions from the past. And the
beautiful part is that the the wiki is
never frozen, right? Similar to the
research entity files. At any point, you
can ingest a new custom link that you
think that you need into the wiki, or
even run a new deep research round. Or
as I said previously, the wiki keeps
evolving just purely based on your
questions.
And another important thing to
understand is that this wiki doesn't sit
on top your of your entire second brain,
right? For example, in my particular use
case, I use the PARA method coined by
Tiago Forte where all my data is
structured between project, areas,
resources, and archive. Where all my
notes resources that I save, sources
that I save yet article or whatever are
just piped directly to the resource a
flat list. And whenever I need
something, I just references them
into projects and areas, right? And like
this, Obsidian is just an immutable
snapshot that a LLM never touches,
right? So, this is my data. I don't
really want the LLM to touch my personal
notes that I manually write, right? So,
then how can we actually put this wiki
to use, right? So, as I said, we have
the big Obsidian snapshot which is our
global second brain.
And then
whenever we start to work on a new
project, we reference this second brain
through this deep research algorithm
that I explained, and we scope it down
to our own project, right? So,
basically, whenever we want to start
working on something, we run this deep
research loop or we start ingesting some
particular repositories, articles,
notes, and so on and so forth.
And
we usually do that through a set of
skills plugged into a harness.
And a project can be basically anything
such as writing a new article, doing a
new video, doing a set of slides. I I
applied this technique doing this slide.
Or you can even apply it for something
more complex such as writing a book,
doing a course, or or keeping track of a
whole code base, right? You can also you
use it for that. So, basically, a
project can be anything where you want,
as I said initially, to transform
research into work.
The project is the work, and your second
brain is the research.
So, now I want to show you a few demos.
So, what you need to do is go to the AI
research OS workshop repository, and
here you can find all the skills
required to run what we presented into
this presentation.
And everything is packed as a cloud code
plugin, but you can very easily tweak it
and install it with any other harness.
And also in the read me, you can find
details on how to install all all the
other dependencies, because the thing is
that this system is dependent on tools
such as Obsidian, Readwise notebook
elements, and so on and so forth. So,
you need to set up specific CLIs or
authentication issues. But, I don't
really want to waste any of your time
with setup issues, and I want to go
straight directly into the examples. So,
I prepared here three examples. The
first one is a research on one of my
previous articles on agentic AI
engineering, and within these files, I
have a brand dump of everything that I
knew I wanted to talk on this subject.
And on top of that, I also added a few
references that I knew 100% that I want
to add into this wiki.
And what we need to do to actually
trigger the the algorithm on top of
these files is to open up a cloud
session, and then just call the skill,
the research skill, and point it it to
this file. And that's it. Everything
else is baked directly into the skill.
It will understand my intent that I want
to create a wiki
on agentic harness engineering just
looking at these files and looking at
the topic, and it will know that before
starting the deep research algorithm, it
actually needs to scrape this
information to to use it as context when
it frames the questions for the deep
research algorithm.
Now, we need to wait a bit for for the
agent to reason on top of it.
And I will actually just put it on auto
mode to speed speed this up, right? I
use this hundreds of times, so I know it
won't delete anything from my computer
or it won't do anything weird. Okay, so
now this is the most important part,
right? So, it asked me how deep I want
the deep research algorithm to be.
We have light, deep, fast. This mostly
controls how many questions you want to
run per one round and how many rounds
you want to run. And usually light or
fast is more than enough because
remember this process consumes a lot of
tokens. So, you kind of need to do the
deep one only when you you really want
to look over tons and tons of notes. And
for this use case, I will just pick the
light one to to to speed this up. And in
this use case, it just does one round of
three queries, right? And for the
fast one, it does two rounds of three
queries. So, I would just keep it keep
it around that spectrum.
And now the process
will will take around 10 to 20 minutes
to actually look around my Obsidian, to
look around my Readwise, my Notebook LM,
and run those queries on top of this.
And I actually run this, right?
And now let's open this wiki that we
created based on the prompt before in
Obsidian and let's look what's inside
the the wiki.
So, we have three big objects, the raw
files, which are basically a raw copy of
what we found, the index,
which contains all the references to
towards the wiki, right? We can also in
Obsidian have this beautiful a subgraph
where we can very quickly understand
what is going on. This is created purely
based on this this file.
And then the most interesting part is
inside the wiki.
Where we have comparisons,
concepts, entities,
and sources. The sources contain the
executive summary of of our raw sources.
So, the LLM doesn't really need to every
time when it reads them, and it needs
them to to read the raw sources, but it
needs just the executive summaries,
which are computed just one time during
the ingestion. And for example, for the
comparisons, it understood out of the
box that it needs to do comparisons
between like adjective rag versus file
systems or compaction versus recursive
language models or or or anything of
interest
based on on the sources. And the most
interesting part is actually the
concepts. So, it automatically extracted
all the
concepts that we need to understand from
this pile of resources. For example, if
we open the agent loop resources, we
automatically
can look and get this beautiful summary
containing like graphs, tags, and
explaining us everything that we need on
this topic. And we can do the same on
all the concepts from from from this
wiki or
all the entities from the wiki and so
and so forth.
Okay, so now let's go to the second
example.
It It's a simple example where I want to
learn more on harness engineering and
how harnesses work. So, in in this
prompt over here, I just want to ingest
the three open source repositories on
open code, Pi, and Hermes.
And I don't want to do deep research at
all, right? I just want to ingest those
repositories and explore topics such as
the general architecture, agents
architecture, sub agents, memory system,
and the agent permission flow. And let's
run the research on top of this prompt.
And now what the research will do will
clone automatically all these
repositories
and will explore all the repositories on
the topics that I gave here
and it will create notes at the
individual level of each repository on
how they work, on how how the
architecture works at the repository
level and then we can create higher
level notes, right? Within the wiki
derivatives and compare all the
architectures or create aggregate
architectures on on like the general
trends of all those harnesses and
basically explore and learn everything
that we want about harness engineering
directly from the code.
And again, usually I just do auto mode
and let it do its own gist, but I
already run this, right? So here is the
wiki for these GitHub repositories
and again, we have the raw files and we
have the index and the wiki.
And here probably within the repos we
can see all the three repositories and
for example, inside the open core
repositories we can see empty files
explaining everything that we need on
particular topics such as the permission
flow, the memory system and so on and so
forth and we can see this in all the
other repositories and the most
interesting part here is actually that
we have comparisons on all of these,
right? So we can actually understand the
differences
within the architecture within these
harnesses or
we also have all the concepts extracted
from these repositories and we can
understand what are the key
architectural decisions from these
repositories.
So we can go crazy with this and this is
super useful if you want to, for
example, write your own harness.
And the third examples is the simplest
one in in reality, which is just based
on ingesting some some simple links,
right? And again, I will just exit the
the previous run and
I want to run this example from scratch.
And here,
I just want to show you that you can use
this
also with a very basic setup where I
just want to ingest three custom random
links.
And as before, I just pass this prompt
and it will start the research process.
And I want to highlight that you can run
example two ending on the GitHub
repositories and this example without
any other setup like without setting up
Obsidian, Readwise, or anything else.
You can just install this plugin and run
this examples because it here is not
dependent on any other service than Git
and using curl to get this this URLs.
And again, here if we go into Obsidian
and explore the wiki created out of this
example three,
we we can see the index, we can see the
wiki itself
with all the sources, right? One
executive summary for for each source
and all the concepts, extracted
entities, and so on and so forth.
And the idea is that as you start asking
questions on top of this, everything
starts to get more interesting. So now,
let's assume that we want to ask for
example a question on harness
engineering based on the wiki created
out of the GitHub repositories. So what
we have to do is just again hit the
research field
pointed to the
wiki that we just created,
and then just ask our question. And
let's assume that I want to learn more
on sandboxing,
more exactly how
remote
sandboxing works and how is
plugged into the heart.
This can be basically any any any other
question. And
now what it will happen, it will
basically query this wiki, it will give
you an answer, and
based on this, you can also start
creating notes, comparisons, or maybe it
will extract and find new entities that
you care about. So basically, it will
start updating the wiki.
>> All right. So now, where is this project
going? What is it? What should you do?
First, it's still rough at some points.
Like it needs more connectors, as you
saw. We need to add Google Drive,
Notion, Slack, and tons of other
connectors that could be useful to you.
But to be honest, it's not really useful
to me and my current workflow or to
Paul. So we didn't add them yet, because
the core of this project is to be useful
for us and for you to take over and add
whatever you need. And the other main
goal of this project is to teach memory
and context management. So all these
extra features aren't really useful
towards that purpose. There are other
some weaknesses, like it's hard to know
which sources are outdated or weak or
strong compared to some other system
that we built. So we know we can improve
this, but again, it's not really the
priority here. And lastly, it's still
obviously a builder workflow. You use it
through cloud code and Codex, and it's
just to me in the terminal and I just
really like it. So it's not a final
polished product with a nice UI, nice
UX. And honestly, that's by design. So
we don't really care about this, because
our goal is to teach AI engineering.
It's not to build the next best product.
Still, we have a few next improvements
we want to do very shortly, from having
a stronger linting to a better memory
compaction, because that's a big issue
and it's just very complicated in
general to manage memory correctly, and
the state of the art is always
progressing there. We, as I said, need
better source provenance to trust the
sources and be able to rank them
properly and reuse them properly if
needed and be able to know access
quickly as a user if this source is
relevant or not.
And we have other
next improvements to do.
But those are mostly for optimization
and for the future. And the thing is
that we actually build all of that into
another product that
you can even build yourself.
Because we created a course called Agent
Engineering
where we build a similar deep research
system with a writing and research agent
where we build a system with the same
goal to be able to learn best AI
engineering practices. It's a very
in-depth course where I assume it takes
around 60 hours to complete with a final
project being the multi-agent system I
just described that you'll build for
yourself. So if this presentation and
the demo repo that you saw was
interesting, please consider checking
out the Towards AI Academy with our
courses on there including the Agent
Engineering course to learn more on the
best practices when building around and
with agents.